bondi beach is one of the most popular
beaches in australia bandai rescue is a
reality tv show that covers some of the
drama that goes down on the beach here
are some of the most wild medical
emergencies that have happened on the
show
getting out of the water ready and then
we'll start compressions up here all
right super important here getting
people obviously out of the water for
safety and everyone's safety is of
utmost priority calling for help is the
number one thing you do you don't just
yell at you point to someone and say you
call 9-1-1 otherwise everyone assumes
everyone else calls 9-1-1 and i know i
always say start chest compressions
first but for drowning victims you do
two rescue breaths first mouth to mouth
because the mechanism of why someone is
heart has stopped and they're not
breathing in the water is very different
than what happens on land okay who's
doing i'm going i'm going i'm going one
two three four five six seven
take it down come on
back good depth two inches deep on those
chest compressions good speed a hundred
beats per minute
ready 20.
all right so the fact that he's vomiting
means right away you have to turn him
over onto his side in order to help
clear that airway in drowning
emergencies it's truly airway breathing
circulation like you have to focus on
the breathing when you find someone on
the street who's collapsed and how hard
has stopped you can do hands-only cpr
but here you have to think about the
airway let me explain the difference
here actually this is important new ones
when you find someone on the street and
they've collapsed their heart has
stopped beating but they've recently
just oxygenated their blood so there's
still some residual oxygen left in the
blood throughout the body even though
it's delivered most of it so as you
perform hands-only cpr you can circulate
that blood and deliver that remaining
oxygen when someone is drowned they
usually have no oxygen reserves
therefore are very hypoxic in their
blood doing hands-only cpr does them a
disservice instead of giving them some
rescue breaths also a lot of people
think that the lungs get filled up with
water the airway actually clamps itself
off and prevents water from going to the
lungs and whatever small amount of water
gets into the lungs actually gets
absorbed systemically so it's really
about getting oxygen in there as quickly
as possible and pumping to help the
heart pump that blood throughout the
body by actually squeezing the heart
physically get someone to come up and
get a defeat the defib is in the tower
but dunno can't leave the control post
unmanned the defibrillator is something
that we use to check if the patient has
any sort of shockable rhythm a lot of
times in grey's anatomy you'll see
someone go flatline they say oh my god
get the defibrillator shock them that's
not a shockable rhythm what happens is
the defibrillator actually stops the
rhythm of your heart breaks that rhythm
and allows it to restart so if someone
doesn't have a rhythm they're completely
flat and you reshock them you make it
flat again that doesn't help them at all
at that point it's more about doing the
chest compressions and giving them
medications to advance cardiac life
support like epinephrine
he's now been clinically dead for three
minutes
and the way you're doing this is 30
pumps uh for every two breaths so you do
30 pumps at a speed of 100 per minute
give two breaths continue
it's critical that no one touches the
man's body while it is shocked
i know you can't touch you don't touch
your touch don't touch it you get
electrocuted check airway
breathing if needed begin cpr so the
modern defibrillators are really good in
that they analyze the rhythms and you
don't have to look at the rhythm and try
and figure out what's going on it will
say non-shockable rhythm continue cpr or
shockable rhythm remove all people from
defibrillator then you hit shock it says
shocking on three shock shock shock and
then it'll deliver the shock so that you
know not to be touching the person i've
got a pulse i have a pulse
responding
let's go let's go
see if he wants to love it yeah
you've got a lot of fuel coming out that
we want to do that's good
don't keep it bagging him if he's
conscious and he's breathing i know like
there's a lot of stuff happening right
now but you could actually force some of
that vomiting aspiration back into the
lungs you don't want to do that
he's still not out of danger yet
everyone stop clapping like you just
watched the jerry springer episode
he was without oxygen for a long period
of time and that guy keeps putting this
stupid ambu mask on him stop it he's
awake now portuguese man award jellyfish
commonly known as blue bottles are blown
onto the coast by onshore winds blue
bottles have rightly earned the label
floating terror i've seen thousands of
people that have been stung by blue
bottles but
this day i'd it was the biggest welt
i've ever seen oh yeah they basically
leave like whiplash looking marks on
your skin creating a type of dermatitis
it's actually really cool how this
happens so they have these pneumaticists
that are at the end of their test
testicles
tentacles when they they hit you with
them and they touch you they actually
attach to your skin and then inject the
poison in it and there's been some
evidence that putting vinegar onto them
can actually help deactivate that venom
and those nematicists nine-year-old zach
has suffered a blue bottle sting over
his entire leg
[Applause]
all right dad maybe give yourself a hug
like there's there's toughening you get
up but when they're experiencing real
big pain give them a hug
zach's father is back on his feet as
lifeguards administer the green whistle
[Music]
[Applause]
the sweet sound of silence
these lifeguards are like can you shut
this kid up they got to get high he
calmed down
oh no i hope she's not having an
anaphylactic attack and have you had an
allergy action before yeah
left untreated victoria's throat will
become so swollen she may be unable to
breathe this type of allergic reaction
called anaphylaxis actually leads to
swelling of the air of the air pipe it
also can create swelling of the mouth it
can lead to nausea vomiting in some
cases and one of the most dangerous
things about anaphylaxis outside of
closing your throat is the major drop of
blood pressure because it dilates your
blood vessels therefore tanking your
blood pressure not getting enough blood
circulation to those vital organs it
could potentially lead to death this is
why a lot of people think oh just treat
it with benadryl but benadryl doesn't
treat that part of anaphylaxis that's
why we need to use these epipens to
boost up the cardiac output and decrease
the swelling of the oral pathway
lifeguard's best chance of saving
victoria is via a shot of adrenaline
from an epipen and i'm sure many of you
have heard the story i've had to do
something like this in the air while
flying on a gentleman who did not have
an epipen so we had to concoct the
epipen through medications that you
would actually use if someone's heart
stops and they were flatlining same
medication different dosage i had to do
that calculation kind of on the fly
there was no wi-fi because we were
flying over the atlantic ocean it was a
crazy scene and also this auto injector
is nice and thin and small the needle so
it's not going to cause a lot of
discomfort the one that i had to use is
made for a crash cart so it's like a
really thick long needle and i had to
jam it into his thigh he was not happy
with me but he was happy after the fact
when he survived thank you dr mike i
really appreciate your help man so i hit
her with the epipen bang held it in for
10 seconds and um i thought that was
going to be it yeah okay lay down
sweetheart
there we go
stay with this you're right
when she dropped on us i was so scared
and i thought maybe this would be a
resource i suspect what's happening here
is probably a vasovagal reaction when
you get really nervous that she
essentially lost blood supply to her
brain temporarily from seeing the needle
go into her thigh this happens quite
often in fact the gentleman after i
injected him with the syringe he started
telling me that he thought his throat
was feeling weird and closing again when
i looked into it it actually was
completely open i had to use my iphone
flashlight to do so i realized what was
happening was because i gave him
adrenaline his throat dried up his mouth
dried up like you would when you're
giving a speech and you get nervous and
as a result he felt like it was closing
in but it actually wasn't so it was good
that i was able to check that and not
necessarily stick him again with an
unnecessary medication and needle andrea
and her cousin gerald were taking
advantage of iconic bondi as a backdrop
for a rollerblading video when things
went horribly wrong
probably oh patella dislocation it's
actually really easy to pop back in but
wow really all you do is you put
pressure on the outside of the leg and
extend the leg at the same time and then
it just puts it right back into place
and i'm gonna just gently manipulate
your knee i mean i like your wording i
know it's not going to be gentle
breathing
pressure pressure pressure pressure a
little more pressure and he rolled off
seriously there you go
it's going to pop right back in there
you go it goes from pain level 10 to
zero almost instantly a man's found
floating lifeless in the surf see that's
sometimes the worst situation because
you don't know how long they've been
under that surf poppo can't detect a
pulse then right away two rescue breaths
chest compressions let's go he's not
breathing
first time oh much faster he needs to go
much faster with those chest
compressions the third shock has finally
had an effect it's getting stronger
when you get someone back from uh having
no pulse and no breathing it's an
amazing feeling the adrenaline rush of
it yeah i can attest to that for them
they're doing this usually on younger
healthy people i'm doing this sometimes
on people who are older who have a lot
of medical conditions they have a young
healthy person who got really sick
really fast because they drowned then
they rescue them they restart their
heart and now they're better and they're
almost like back to normal real quick
for me i have to then now stabilize that
patient get medications going check
their vitals make sure that their blood
pressure is too low get them on pressers
to artificially raise their blood
pressure get them admitted into the icu
transfer them to a different team of
care but this is tough because you
cannot control this environment i have
much more control of my environment when
i'm in the hospital
i still don't know
oh i don't know about sea urchins a sea
urchin is
a little sea creature with all these
little sparks that come off it and
they kind of hide in the rock crevices
oh
dude why do people go in the ocean just
hang out on shore sea urchin spikes
carry toxin and are extremely brittle
like needles of fine porcelain they
easily break and yet we tell kids go
play in the ocean there's spikes with
poison in there future generations will
look at us and be like what's wrong with
these people jesse and harrison start
the delicate operation oh man removing
the spines one at a time
can they like numb him up give him a
little lighter cane jesus christ
oh look at that
i was told that he was having low sugar
levels i've dealt with diabetics and low
blood sugar levels before and i know
that they need soft drink or they need
something sweet to bring those
sugar levels back up it could be
hypoglycemic as they're saying because
those who are diabetic struggle to
control their blood sugars and sometimes
they do drop especially if they give
themselves excess medication by accident
and then he pulled out from around his
neck that he also
was an epileptic i mean just call an
ambulance like i hate that they're
always trying to solve and figure out
everyone's medical histories like
clearly this person's going through
something and they need help and you're
not qualified to deliver that help at
this moment do you want me to call an
ambulance yes
yes
he's clearly having an epileptic fit
what was your name again
what was your name again man
he's having like an epileptic seizure
all i could do was hold his pulse and i
was basically waiting to see what would
happen next that's actually what you do
during one of those if they last over a
certain period of time we can medicate
them in the hospital but otherwise you
just have to let it happen in fact
restraining them and holding them down
can actually cause muscle damage
you're right you're with us
you're almighty post-ictyl phase which
is this time after your seizure is
actually a very weird time for not only
the patient but also for providers
because patients oftentimes have amnesia
and don't know what has happened they
don't know where they are they sometimes
can be extremely aggressive so it's
really important that there's people
there to keep them calm explain what
happened and uh diffuse the situation
i've had patients throw stuff at me well
having a type 1 diabetic
and what it does it blows me sugar
so i can go into a hypo any kind
anyway a person with type 1 diabetes is
someone who has an autoimmune condition
that has resulted in the destruction of
the cells that produce insulin so you do
not have enough insulin on your own to
facilitate the sugar leaving your blood
and going into cells where it needs to
function so what ends up happening is
those patients need insulin artificial
insulin to be injected into them in
order for them to function normally and
sometimes if you don't gauge how much
insulin you're putting in in comparison
to how much carbs and sugars you're
consuming you could actually cause
yourself to become hypoglycemic have
very low blood sugar which can lead to
seizures with the crowded surf full of
beginners it's only a matter of time
before the first collision
my god lifeguards won't attempt to put a
severe dislocation back in place the
only time we do like a reduction in the
field is if we see neurovascular
compromise meaning that there's not
enough blood circulation going to an
area and as a result part of that area
is dying then the risks may warrant um
doing that procedure oh my god is he
gonna just pop it in
what a champ
i can't even watch this
that's terrible because the hand has so
many vital structures in it blood
vessels nerves this is why we have hand
surgeon specialists it's not enough to
send someone to an orthopedic surgeon
send them to a hand surgeon my guy's
just here like
with my ice inside slightly out slightly
out it's broken my guy i get over there
and there's a gentleman sitting against
the drain part in a puddle of water
quite calm at this stage saying he's
dislocated his head a dislocated hip
could be one of the most painful things
ever he's had a hip replacement oh my
god
they're not ready for the level of pain
this person's about to experience moving
him to the ambulance will cause enormous
pain
paramedics administer morphine yeah it's
a bumpy ride over rocks and sand before
danny reaches the ambulance
he's not faking it
bo and harry's help a disoriented man
with a mystery ailment
yeah his condition is getting worse by
the seconds
suddenly he stops breathing if he stops
breathing you start chest compressions
he's not a drowning victim
eventually he comes around
that's here to relax as much as possible
lifeguards need his medical history well
they don't need his medical history they
need to call an ambulance and they need
his medical history
oh he has cold water urticaria later
doctors confirmed matt suffers a rare
allergic reaction to cold water that
causes hives
matt's swim had sent him into
anaphylactic shock well an epipen would
have gone a long way there but they
couldn't have known that you don't
recklessly just give epipens to random
people
here are some of the worst fitness
mistakes my patients may click here to
check that out as always stay happy and
healthy look at my tail
[Music]